luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to my
show today is going to be really interesting
we're talking bitfinex we're talking tether and
i have a really exciting guest but as always
this is powered by icon plus i'm going to
give you a really quick news announcement so
this one's really interesting pay coin is the very
first company to commercialize bitcoin payments in
south korea and will also actually integrate ics
and ethe into its global payment app so that's
really interesting this is sponsored by blockbuy
um you can actually earn up to 8.6 percent
interest on your uscc so i will leave a link for
you somewhere and you can get 250 when you sign
up and it is powered and sponsored by coinflip as
well so quick shout out to them so before i bring
on my guest and before we jump into this um if you
are watching on youtube then please don't forget
to hit the like button please don't forget to
subscribe so you never miss one of these fantastic
guests joining me today we have haley lennon
partner at anderson kill law and contributor for
forbes crypto haley great to have you how are
you doing hi great thanks for having me it's very
exciting to come on it's good to have you i feel
like we've been chatting for ages and we've been
trying to schedule something in but it's just been
it's been madness how are you over in california
good i am yeah it's been i thought things might
calm down with covid and it's been quite the
opposite um i just re i was based in san francisco
the last four years and just relocated outside of
san francisco so that's been a nice sort of change
of pace and like you said i joined anderson kill
it's been about four months those four months have
flown by and i'm really enjoying it i'm helping
to grow out the regulatory practice um there
we we have four or five partners including uh
preston byrne and stephen palley which are both
also active on twitter um as other partners at the
firm and so we're just growing out our practice
there for crypto and fintech companies it's
it's been really fun yeah and i think i think
people like yourself who are in the regulatory
side of things i think are so interesting and
brilliant to chat to because on twitter it's
kind of just like this hub where we're all sort
of just crowding and shouting things and ideas
but realistically you know we need to know how
this is all going to play out in the grand scheme
of things you know what's mass adoption going to
look like so i'm excited to jump in but before we
do how did you get into cryptics i don't know a
lot about you personally so tell me your journey
yeah it's been interesting so i graduated law
school in 2012 and i thought i wanted to just
go like big law commercial litigation be
in a courtroom and after about a year um
at a law firm i was like this is just not for
me i i really decided that i wanted to be either
in-house or just working in a in a specific
field that i was really passionate about so
i am i started doing in-house counsel work for
traditional finance companies and then i was
recruited by silvergate bank in 2014 because
they wanted to help bank the crypto space
at that time you know even the large reputable
exchanges couldn't get a bank account because
there was this impression that you know
there was more money laundering going on
used for criminal activity all these sort of like
narratives and um so i joined silvergate and i i
had known about bitcoin and um my boyfriend at the
time and i had started buying a little but it was
still just i was getting my head wrapped around it
and then when i joined silvergate it was like um
my job was reviewing every major exchange in every
major crypto company to see if they had a you
know a compliance program a information security
program cyber security all the things that would
be needed to make a company safe and bankable
and so by the time i left silvergate after like
two and a half years i had reviewed um in like 200
300 crypto companies and i had this like amazing
bird's eye view of the industry and like where
everyone sat the results of certain exchanges
regulatory exams just like the whole
world of what was going on at that time
um and then i moved up to san francisco and and
started to focus more on in-house counsel for
specific companies so i was at bitfire which
is uh the largest bitcoin exchange in japan
and at the time they wanted to expand into the u.s
so i helped them get the new york bit license and
all the you know requirements to expand here into
the united states which is no small task and then
most recently was at coinbase's regulatory council
so um it's been a really exciting journey and like
with every year i spend in the industry i fall
more in love with it and just like the people in
it and what we're all doing and um you know even
as nerdy as it sounds like the legal implications
and what we what we're having to deal with so
it's really exciting yeah i can imagine because
like i was saying there's just so much going on
and we just don't know what we can and can't do
and whether it be major institutions getting in
whether it be you know taxes whether it be which
countries are doing what there's just so much
going on and i think people like yourself are just
so important just to be like wait hold up like we
need some information as to what what is happening
so so did you did you know anything then
about crypto before you delved into it did
you sort of just learn on the job well what's
funny is like so before silvergate i was at a
traditional currency exchange company so um in
i was in san diego that's where i went to law
school and in san diego there are small exchange
centers along the mexico border where workers
either on the mexico side or the united states
side need to like be exchanging their pesos
for dollars they're you know depositing
their um paychecks that sort of thing that
also has money laundering concerns it can have
money transmitter licensing implications so that's
part of the reason silvergate recruited me is
they were saying well you know what you're doing
at this traditional wholesale currency exchange
company is actually very much in line with crypto
i mean crypto's sexier it has more like
tech behind it it's more revolutionary but
when you get down to the basics like people
can use it for money laundering so you need to
have an anti-money laundering program uh it can be
considered money transmission so you need licenses
in every state and so there's actually like a
lot um there was a lot of similarities where
there was definitely learning on the job i mean
it's when i started looking at um when i started
learning about chain analysis and elliptic uh
and when i was at silvergate bitcoin was the only
coin that existed like there was like that was in
the early days where the what is the security and
what is not didn't exist but um but yeah so there
was a lot of learning on the job but you know the
silvergate bank team is still around that bank
is thriving with their crypto practice and so
there was a really great team to learn with you
know and like uh expand our knowledge on the space
so outside of the as i said outside of crypto what
else did you do in your spare time other than stay
locked home because you're covered um yeah outside
of crypto what else do what else are you up to
yeah hobbies seem funny now um well so even
before covet but now i've definitely been
focusing more on cooking i used when i was in
law school and waiting for my law bar results i
started like a very amateur cooking blog um but
you know what would you cook i mean i love pastas
i um i don't do like baking i just do like the
savory um i've been i've been playing around
more with the grill lately and marinades and that
sort of thing so just just anything i really like
um you know i go through a lot of cooking books
and cooking magazines and just sort of like
use recipes and tweak tweak them a little um but
also like i mean in southern california right
now the beach i mean i love just going
to the beach walking around with my dog
yeah it is it is a 74 where i am right now
and um and i'm originally from dallas so all
my friends last week were dealing with the like
you know yeah power outages um snow and i feel
very fortunate like for the weather we're
experiencing here and so yeah just hiking
um but kovitz changed things i mean before covid i
loved um like yoga classes you know going dancing
like concerts sporting events i mean so the
world's just changed right now yeah i'm with you
um but yeah it's a shame oh gosh me and
no one ever asks me what do i like really
put me on the spot i like i like the sun like
i like i like outdoors i like nature i'm hoping
i'm should be leaving the uk permanently really
soon so i'm hoping just to get in the sun beach
i like dancing as well um i'm not amazing at
cooking which is annoying but other than that
other than that you know cool well i won't i won't
put you on the spot and ask where you're going
but um i hope it's somewhere where somewhere
fun i will you'll let me know i'll announce
it soon yeah i'll announce it soon so i promised
everybody that we would talk about heather because
tether's been crazy we've had this tether filed
that it's you know not backed one-to-one with
the dollar that it's um you know pumping up
the price of bitcoin so obviously yesterday
we heard the news that tether and bitterness
obviously agreed to settle um with the new
york state attorney for 18.5 million dollars
so can you take us through and understand what
exactly is happening here yeah i mean it's
hard because there is a lot of sort of like
what what new york is saying versus what bitfinex
is saying and what you know what what they're
claiming so the situation with any sort of stable
coin like this and i'll use quote mark stable coin
is that the coin is pegged to something
it can be it can be the dollar it can
be a basket of assets it can it can really be
anything but it needs to be pegged to that to
um help ensure that there's less volatility
um and and that there is consumer protection
efforts involved and so you know i definitely do
think that a lot of the news not even just about
tether but just in general is fun you know people
like to have click bait titles um make it seem
like this whole thing is this like scary industry
wild wild west i mean we've been dealing with that
for like 10 years just that general narrative um
and it's that's something i really try to avoid
writing for forbes like i would get paid
per click but i'd rather the title be and
the article really wait you get paid per click i
didn't know that contributors do i mean there's
there's certain like yeah certain i think certain
news um news places do per click some do um so
at least for contributors uh and that's i mean
and not just forbes like journalism in general
sometimes you are um incentivized to make sure
that it's something that is going to cause you
know stir or get attention so anyways my point
is just that like i think that there is fud
out there about this and about everything but
um but i think the settlement shows you know
they were the companies and the project was
very careful not to like admit guilt really
in that settlement but it also shows um that they
weren't wanting to continue sort of fighting and
and proving it wrong i would say um or they
didn't want to continue using their resources and
and money to keep fighting it um so you
know it's hard it's hard to say really but
i do think that there seems to be something going
on where it's not it's not a hundred percent
true that it's pegged one for one to the dollar or
wasn't at a certain point in time um and i think
it's sort of that that um dishonesty that
is is leading to new york pursuing this so
aggressively because if you have um consumers that
are relying on things that a project is claiming
um and then those things end up not being true you
know consumer protection has always been i think
something that people actually don't focus a ton
on in the industry they're they're busy with the
sec and uh fenson and ofac but you know we don't
we don't want a bunch of consumers being hurt by
misinformation so um but it's interesting and
you know i don't i don't personally have a lot of
opinion on whether tether was doing things to
um manipulate or change the price of bitcoin i i
don't think that that's that's not what could like
would concern me about the situation um but it
didn't help the news didn't help bitcoin's price
yesterday i would say yeah absolutely it didn't um
but see where i get really stumbled across um
these when it comes to these things is the fact
that they had to settle for 18.5 million despite
the fact that they still denied any wrongdoing
so i'm just so uncomfortable with that because
i do understand the point in settling i get it
like you said you know here just take the money
and we'll call it a day i get that but if there
was no wrongdoing surely you can tell me if i'm
wrong anyone in the comments can tell me if i'm
wrong but if there was no wrong doing 18.5
million no it's not it's not it's not like
a couple thousand and i know it's obviously not
that much for them but it's a it's a hefty it's
a hefty amount for not doing anything wrong yeah
i mean i i think i think you're getting at the the
argument though that probably that that that
amount of money isn't that much in compared to
what what they've been able to you know yeah make
um so it's it's more based probably on percentage
but um but i would agree i mean i don't i think
that you know companies get put in this hard
position where they need to choose if they're
going to continue fighting and like you said pain
and spending the time and money to try to prove
their innocence or if they're just gonna say you
know what let's just call it a day um and and i
think likely that's part of what's happened here
um but there's also a situation you could
argue where if if all the facts were really
in your favor you would keep going you know you
would you would continue to fight fight the good
fight so it's hard to say yeah and i don't know
if anyone in the comments does have does have
an opinion about that but in general i would
just say that the the amounts that were seen
in these settlements and even like um enforcement
enforcement actions like they do seem very high i
mean there was um an article i read a few weeks
or months ago where bitgo settled with ofac for
um i think it was nine thousand dollars of
transactions that that went to prohibited
jurisdictions so it's not like they went to
someone on the ofac sdn terrorist list they
went to jurisdictions that that of themselves are
considered on the blocked list and so for nine
thousand dollars of transactions they settled for
almost a hundred thousand dollars you know and so
you start to like i feel the same way sometimes
where i'm looking at it and i'm thinking like
you know it's just it's getting it getting it out
of the way and um but sometimes it does seem a
little like unbalanced do you have an opinion on
it so do you think that there was any wrongdoing
on teddy's part or are you not allowed to sort
of give me um i i don't think they're completely
innocent i think there must be i you know i
don't look regulators um some regulators may have
a problem with this space but regulators don't
just like go after a company for no reason and so
for new york to be kind of um pretty transparent
and saying there was um misrepresentation about
the backing i think that i think it's
fair to say that that's partially true
i don't know how true and i don't know the the
gravity of it um but that's that's what i'll say
i wanna so i think that leads me on to the
next thing that i wanna talk about because
the um ripple um i think it's called sec versus
howie i think that's the name of the official um
court case so that obviously happened there was
there was an amendment that happened this week
so i wanted to get your opinion on it um and i
kind of want to go through it chronologically so
i'm thinking i want to first understand and i know
i've been through this but i still think there's
um some confusion around i do want to understand
what a security is why they're being accused of
being a security um the amendment and and
then and then we'll go on so let's let's do
this chronologically because i think it's quite a
hefty subject so go for it yeah so um yeah so sort
of the background is that there was the case
the sec versus howie um it was from 1946 and
um you know i don't want to like sort of repeat
what everyone knows but for anyone who doesn't
it was actually about an orange grove and what
the case was trying to litigate and determine is
when is something an investment contract when is
someone um relying on efforts by someone in hopes
of um making money it's just kind of as
simple as that so you know that was 1946
the securities act is from 1933 so we're dealing
with like case law and um and regulation very old
and so now you fast forward to present day and um
and there's been a lot of confusion around this
because um ver pretty early on the sec sort of
said how the howie test that comes from that
court case is the same test that you need to
apply to kryptos so that's sort of the basic
um i don't do we can talk about like what those
four like there's four pro yeah yeah go for it
essentially i think i think the confusion is like
because ether was kind of ruled out as not being
a security so why is that different to xrp yeah
that's that's a fair question so so um at the very
basic the howie test determines if something is an
investment contract and so there's four prongs um
it's if there was a common enterprise an
investment of money in that common enterprise
with the expectation of profits derived from
the efforts of others and i do so for those four
um to be an investment contract you have
to meet all four and that might seem
difficult but actually i would argue that a lot
of the projects in the space meet those four
and i'd argue the same that's how my confusion
comes in yeah and it's not a very popular opinion
and i actually have a lot of potential clients
that come to me and say you know we want to do
this this is what we want to do and they
lay out the things they're wanting to do
with their project and their token and i say what
you just described as an investment contract like
so we can either figure out ways to get rid of
one of those prongs um and you know not to get
around the law but like to to frame your project
in a different way or let's go talk to the sec
let me just ask you this then so with that in
mind then if you sort of feel like you know
this is a common denominator within the space
do you feel that the sec are going after
ripple xrp specifically because they believe that
they've done something wrong or do you think this
is a general sort of attack on the space because
i guess you know they were doing things in some
ways they were looking to re you know replace the
banks in terms of those international payments so
so i don't i don't interpret it as like an attack
on the industry or like trying to promote the bank
um i mean there's definitely there are
definitely regulators in the us and
there's definitely reasons why some people
want banks to succeed and crypto to fail
like that's i agree with that but when it comes
to ripple like the first thing i'll say is i don't
think ripple's the only project that's going to
see this issue like behind the scenes i think um
it takes the sec a while to sort of accumulate
all the evidence and things they want to include
in a um in a case against a company
so i don't think ripple is the last
of its kind i think we're going to see
it more and i and i don't love that i you
know i really wish that we could as an industry
like have the clarity we've all been asking for
rather than these lawsuits or enforcement actions
so so that's sort of one thing i don't think that
this is the last we'll see of of this and
so i don't think it's specific to ripple but
um part of what i think the issue with ripple
is is that they you know there are a lot of
uh exhibits within the allegations
that ripple uh really sort of marketed
xrp and promoted it and even promised profits so
if you go and like look back at the four prongs
uh an investment of money people did that
in a common enterprise ripple is that
um with the expectation of profits so that's one
prong where you know it's maybe up for debate if
people thought no this is actually like a new
payment rail that we want to support not this
is a coin i want to buy for it to go up that's
one thing you can debate and then derive solely
from the efforts of others i think people make the
argument that ripple feels fairly centralized so
i think that plus the statements that they've uh
you know included in the lawsuit about um sort of
promising the future uh and promising profits or
promising success of the coin and increase value
i think that that is a hard um those are those are
pretty easy facts for the sec to point to and so
you know it's unfortunate like i am i mean people
i think some people who follow me on twitter would
think that i'm like anti-xrp or anti-ripple i'm
not like i i've never invested in it or purchased
that wouldn't answer yet if you haven't if
you haven't invested then you must be asking
so you know and i don't even i don't even hope
that this turns into some horrible thing for
ripple or xrp you know i really don't i i have
no ulterior motives like against the project
but i do think that for now like you know um
crypto mom has like suggested for with the sec
that we have this like she's proposed a three-year
safe harbor that would allow a comp a project like
ripple and xrp to reach that
level of decentralization
um where it could arguably not be a security after
those three years and within those three years
the project would have to disclose a lot of
things but for the time being the sec hasn't
you know pushed that forward hasn't agreed to
that and so we are where we are and it's um and
does it stifle innovation and projects yes 100 um
but it's still the framework we have to work in
i mean that's the kind of narrative that we saw
with ethereum i mean that's why a lot of people
that's why i compared it to because it's kind
of the what i keep hearing people often like
you know that's what people did with the theorem
at first and now it's decentralized and so on but
there was one of them there was an amendment this
week which changed it so can you explain what this
amendment was um i believe it's quite a good thing
essentially for yeah so i wasn't following it as
closely this week as i normally would but they
did um there was an amendment where the sec has
amended some of its claims and i believe removed
the um manipu market manipulation claim yeah
that isn't um that isn't saying that the sec like
the sec is still moving forward with its claims
that it was an unregistered security offering
um but i think that that is a positive if you're
you know following um because it shows it shows
that some of the claims that the sec initially
included um are being dropped but um you
know i i i think it'll be interesting because
we're not getting sort of any there's there's
a chance that the sec made that amendment
to help promote a settlement but uh okay but
what i think more so is probably that they
dropped that you know that they made the amendment
but that this may actually go all the way to
to trial and um you know i think that'll be
really interesting and again i don't i don't
have any like specific hopes on the outcome
of that but i do if it goes all the way to um
you know litigation and it doesn't settle well we
might start to get some clarity or we it may just
be yeah it hit these four prongs and we're gonna
all be like back back to where we started but
the most interesting part of all of this for
me is kind of just like trying to understand
where this is gonna look in the future so
do you think if you know there's clarity
is given and we understand whether it is
or isn't a security but number one by the
time that happens would something would
would another project have come along and
you know done what xrp was going to do and you
know replace swift and so on or do you think
actually now that it has that clarity even if
it is let's say two three years down the line it
can actually go on to do what it's supposed to do
and all those bag holders are gonna be real happy
yeah i don't it's hard to tell i mean i guess
my hope really would be this safe harbor thing
would move forward i'm a big fan of it i wrote an
article in forbes about it and you know there's
been a change within the sec gary ginsler is now
there um from the statements i've heard from him
though i actually think that he i don't think he's
skeptical or dislikes the space but i do think
that he has been pretty clear that he he thinks
xrp you know ripple is a security and that um
you know that even other projects i've seen
statements by him about facebook's libra project
and things like that so you know it's hard it's
really hard to tell it's hard it's hard to see
in the future i you know there's a statute of
limitations within within some of these claims
i think don't quote me but i think it's around
five years for some of these securities uh claims
and so um so we'll we'll start to see i mean
i think i think we'll start to see in the next
i don't know i would say the next few months
there may be some more activity coming out of
the sec and i don't know that because of any
clients i have or anything like that but just
from conversations i'm having in the industry um
maybe the next maybe the next year will give us
some some guidance on where this is all heading
you mentioned um facebook's libra i just wondered
if you had any thoughts on that um like your
opinion on it yeah it's just not taken off i don't
know yeah i think well i think they really kind
of so for one i'm not a huge fan of facebook i
think i mean to me it's like if we could figure
out a way to decentralize facebook and people
could be compensated for their own information
rather than giving it to mark zuckerberg and
making him money off advertising that would be
ideal but um but that aside like i think what
happened with that project is they launched and
they didn't really think about how u.s regulators
would react so so with libra different than like
usdc or tether libra was trying to say okay we're
going to make a stable coin but it's going to
be backed by a basket of assets it's going to be
it's going to have the euro the end like all
these different um and we as a association are
going to determine um what percentage of each and
the us government was like you don't get to choose
monetary policy like that right like you don't
you don't get to make other countries currencies
more or less important than the us dollar in this
like basket of assets so i think it would have had
a much different i think it would have taken off
if it had launched just pegged to the u.s dollar
i'm guessing they didn't because they
were hoping it would be more of a global
currency i guess but i think that's what like
made all those letters come out and hearings and
everything yeah so i don't really know i mean they
they've reached they've changed their name to dm
now um you know so maybe they're looking to sort
of like re-remarket themselves um you know i i've
i was on a panel yesterday with their general
counsel dms and he he's great i mean i was on a
panel with him and brian brooks from the occ um
and and you can j he's really passionate about
the the idea of a stable coin and a digitized
dollar so you know i'm not like i i'm not against
the project at all but i do think they're
they're going to need to pivot a little
yeah 100 they've already i mean facebook number
one has just terrible um connotations to it at
this point i think i think even mark zuckerberg
as an individual people just don't like anymore um
libra to me i just remember when the whole thing
started back in was it 2018 2019 it just never got
any good reputation any good kind of um marketing
or publicity i think i remember the backers
pulled out as well at one point um yeah there was
like 20 people in the association i mean including
uh zappo coinbase i mean there were some exchange
companies uh or crypto companies in there and then
um yeah when all the you know letters from
congress and things started coming out i
mean paypal dropped like there was just like this
avalanche i i believe none of the cryptocurrency
companies pulled out um so i believe that
they're still members of the association
um and so you know i think that that shows that
there is some support or at least that they that
these companies are seeing the potential of it but
it hasn't like it hasn't met that potential yeah
yeah i mean if facebook cryptocurrency digital
asset is inevitable like amazon are talking about
one it's so inevitable um but there's been some
stuff going on in the u.s so i want to get your
thoughts because i'm british and i've no idea
what's happening so just break it down for me so
so so we were kind of talking earlier and i was
sort of really interested in regulation um because
it's a conversation we're always having in terms
of whether it will stifle innovation in this space
um i've been seeing what's been going on
in nigeria and how their central banks
have basically stopped um basically stopped um
financial um regulated financial institutions
from trading cryptocurrency so that's been
damaging there but obviously i want to kind
of get the u.s perspective and whether you number
one imagine anything happening quite like that and
number two i know that um is it janet yellen i
know there's been a lot of hostility with her
and ginzla so who are these characters because
i don't actually know so take me through i guess
how the us landscape looks yeah so so yeah i
mean your first question is do i ever could
i see a world in which there's some sort of that
level of restriction on cryptocurrency in the us
um i i don't i think that what we'll continue
seeing is certain companies or certain projects
struggling with regulatory um you know enforcement
actions or settlements but i don't think that
they'll ever be a situation where um you know
financial institutions are told they can't um
you know they can't be part of the space in some
way and actually what we saw for the last you know
six months or a year was brian brooks who was
formerly the chief legal officer of coinbase i
worked closely with him um and he joined the occ
which is the office of comptroller of currency
so the occ is within the treasury
department of the federal government
and they one of the things they do is handle you
know bank banking regulation and licensing and
so obviously brian is a huge fan of cryptocurrency
he came from coinbase like there's no um that's no
secret and but he but he was able to really go
into the occ and have conversations about like
this is where this things are heading this is
what it means to be a bank and nothing about that
doesn't include the right to
touch cryptocurrency in some way
um so going back to like my silvergate bank
days there were these companies that couldn't
get a bank account and they're still there's
people are still struggling with that right
but like for one if if something is not illegal
like so marijuana for example in the u.s is
illegal on the federal level it still is i don't
think it should be but it is and so that means
a bank is going to have a really hard time
explaining why to their federal regulator or
their regulator in general why they're providing
a bank account to a marijuana company on the other
crypto's not illegal on any level uh you need
to be you know you need to be registered as a
broker if you're going to list a security you
need to have an anti-money laundering program
there's a lot of rules around it but it's
not illegal at all so so even back to the
silvergate bank days or today it's like why
is it hard for a crypto company or a person
buying crypto to have or maintain a bank account
that just seems crazy and so and it's always
seemed crazy to me it's part of what i really
loved about silvergate um but so brian you know
put out a lot of these letters and guidance over
the last six months that said um hey banks you you
can and you should provide bank accounts to crypto
companies national banks like the big name banks
you shouldn't be de-risking and not banking these
companies then you know a few weeks or a month
later he said hey banks you can and should be if
you want and in your business model be custody
and crypto assets like it's no different than the
fact that you've always offered safety security
deposit boxes at your bank like just it's the
technology's different but it's not it's not um
changing or expanding on what a bank can do it's
just keeping up with the time so anyways brian
and the occ made all these great um i would say
like advances for the space and we see anchorage
and some custom some companies actually going
for um special purpose trust charters or full
national bank charters now with the occ and that's
something that never would have happened a year
ago um but then yeah we have this transition
of power the biden administration's coming in
uh and i you know janet yellen is interesting
because she so she's taken over for the treasury
um i i wrote a pretty like strongly worded forbes
article about some of her initial statements
because she kind of came out you know while
she was being nominated and and introduced and
said yeah and i just promoted these things that
like are just so i mean so ten years ago i just
say like i mean so she she had said i forget the
phrasing like that that crypto is is mainly used
for illicit activity and i just lost that yeah
like and i mean my fourth article was professional
i didn't like actually lose my [ __ ] but i
was just like i was close because it was just
like how are we still talking about this and it's
also just ignorant and just like shows a lack of
research and and time i think that's just
intellectual laziness and i think that's kind
of shocking for someone in her position personally
i think it's that and i think it's saying what she
thinks her peers will relate to yes um and that's
frustrating too because you know i mean yeah i
think i think it's kind of based on her audience
and who she's trying to speak to and so i mean
is it we're in an interesting position like
biden has said that he you know when there
were the whole hacks on twitter remember when
like yeah people lost control over twitter
biden was one of them and like the hackers who
took over the accounts on twitter were making it
like a bitcoin like fundraise or some you know
and at that time biden said that he didn't he
confirmed he doesn't own any bitcoin but besides
that he's never said anything else and trump
actually is the one who during his administration
tweeted all that negative stuff about bitcoin
so you know we don't we don't have any indication
that like the biden administration is going to be
harsher or worse for the industry in the us um
but this some of the statements by janet yellen
like this week she said that cryptocurrency is
inefficient yeah these little things that i don't
even know really where they're like i don't
know where they're coming from or even what
what's like what the incentive is to say that you
know what i mean like she can have that opinion
that it's but like i'm not sure where what i think
the incentive yeah i mean the incentive just comes
from the the same way we see banks behave um
hostile towards cryptocurrencies i mean in the uk
banks are absolutely a nightmare sometimes
when it comes to cryptos um the fca who's
our financial contact authority um they're
it's just not so straightforward and i think
it's because they see it as a threat um to
the natural status quo the natural kind of
way and the system basically because i think it
is you know decentralization essentially means
nobody has control nobody's in there's not one
central authority and that's obviously gonna um
rub the establishment the wrong way and i
think that's kind of maybe what it comes
down to um yeah on my on my panel yesterday
when we were talking about stable coins um
the panel sort of was talking about
it as like a baby step because before
you can expect these regulatory agencies like
you're saying to be comfortable with this like
with every with having absolutely no control
and no power and no um sort of even like the
volatility aspect um like to me stable coins are
like the baby step in between it's sort of like
you get the regulators comfortable with stable
coins they're not that volatile they're tied
to your dollar like you know yeah and then get
they're starting to get comfortable with like
centralized exchanges oh it's you know coinbase it
does the same kyc as a bank does everything's okay
you can't just like look i've been in the space
a long time i'm like very into this idea of like
a decentralized exchange where there's really not
this need for like kyc and surveillance but we're
not like in my mind we're not there yet but no
kyc can we get there from a regulatory standpoint
that's a good one yeah yeah it is and then that's
why i'm kind of saying like you know so the reason
i think we maybe can or we can at least get closer
is like um i can sometimes compare this to the
like to the internet days and i've had discussions
with zuko the founder of zcash about this like
when the internet first came about like the
internet providers and even just the hosted
websites really wanted the websites to be
encrypted um and the the government here
in the u.s at least um and this is sort of a
rough analogy because i'm no internet expert but
but the the like the government agencies
and and the government in the us was sort
of like you can't encrypt it like we the law
enforcement needs access to it we need to
they wanted that control and then as um other
countries started like hacking or stealing
information or doing these things all of a sudden
the us government was like oh that sort of like
um privacy element of it less control and
more encryption is actually a good thing
and now that's how the internet is today so like
i don't i don't know if we could ever get to a
place where there's absolutely zero kyc um but
i do think that we're still like having these
baby steps trying to get trying to like get closer
to this idea of like like the libertarian ideals
that started this industry and saying how do we
find that happy medium because like right now
right now i would argue that most of
the centralized exchanges are doing
more transaction monitoring and kyc than banks you
know they're they're doing transaction monitoring
on the fiat side knowing where the dollars are
coming from knowing where the the cryptocurrency
is coming from and going to and you know it's
just it's crazy so um i hope i hope we can get
continue to make progress educating i
mean education is a big part of this like
um even my article about janet
yellen's um statements wasn't to like
um wasn't to like just like try to to make
everyone in the industry feel better it's sort
of like if if people outside of the industry or
even janet yellen herself would like read that or
read chain analysis like report that i referenced
in my article that talks about like i have it i
have a little it's like what did i say it was 2.1
of cryptocurrency transaction volume was used for
illicit activity and money okay and in 2020 that
dropped to just point 34 of transaction volumes
so that literally means less than one percent
of cryptocurrency is used for these reasons and
then janet yellen's over here saying that that's
what they're mainly used for so it's just we have
there's a thing yeah there's a disconnect yeah i
mean i think more than a disconnect there's like a
lack of research there um very insane um but yeah
it will be interesting to see how it plays out
i'll just say quickly because i spoke to um fluffy
pony um about monero and he put it really really
nicely for me he sort of said that um because
we're talking about kyc and privacy obviously
and he sort of said look you know we have cash
right once you have your cash nobody knows whether
you're paying your taxes people don't know um how
much you have stacked under your bed people don't
know whether you're doing something illegal
with it you know buying drugs with it nobody
really knows and he sort of said that's those
same aml procedures will be put into place for
things like privacy coins cryptocurrencies and
so on um i think it's just a matter of moving
forward and innovating because realistically like
if i you know i i receive payment in bitcoin right
so technically if i wanted i could just not pay
tax on that because i just get this bitcoin and
there's no kyc and whatever but then i can't
do anything because when i start you know
buying a house buying a car thinking hang on
leia you have not had an income for you know
yeah so it's absolutely impossible um yeah i
think for some reason this new technology just
scares people and and they make people describe
it and make it seem so like it has so much more
potential for bad than dollars and it doesn't like
you said dollars literally are pieces of paper and
you can go do whatever you want with them so you
know any any like argument i or statements i hear
about bitcoin like that like you can just change
the word bitcoin the dollars and and that sentence
is probably more true so um yeah i mean i i think
that there's a lot of value in financial privacy
i think that like you know the at least in
the u.s like the events of september 11th
and now even covet in a way are being used to
justify more control and more surveillance and
being already being argued like we're protecting
you you you know we're protecting you but um
yeah i don't know as my favorite quote goes when
tyranny comes it will come wrapped in the flag
that's my my favorite question that's really
good yeah it's amazing um i'll just just off the
back of that actually um i shouldn't get into
this but i'll just say it's the same thing in
the uk so we're not patriotic like you are we we
don't care about the flag here actually if you
um if you wave a flag it's offensive um even
especially in england flag you mustn't wave an
england flag because that means that you're a nazi
and um a skinhead and so on that's basically what
that means um but the way that we show patriotism
is through our public services like our national
health service or nhs um so that's our patriotism
so this whole covert thing for us is all about
protect the nhs save lives protect the nhs you
know so that's kind of the way so that's our flag
our nhs is our flag so when tyranny comes it comes
wrapped in the nhs so it's the same thing same
thing but different yeah yeah that's interesting
i i love hearing just like how the different
yeah how different places uh view some of these
topics because and there there are topics that
i don't like i think that a lot of people in the
crypto space um like maybe these topics wouldn't
be things that they think about so passionately
if it weren't for cryptocurrency you know what
i mean like i've always been passionate about
this idea of of um like liberties and freedom and
not being surveilled um but if it weren't for
cryptocurrency i'm not sure i'd be questioning
the financial system to the level i am so
that it's a pretty like powerful thing that
we're all involved in that fascinates
me um because so a lot of people come
to crypto through crypto first but i find crypto
through politics because i am a libertarian and
i do believe in freedom um and so i come through
the politics angles so i'm so happy that i'm here
because i'm like people understand me yeah
people get me these are your people for sure yeah
and it's neat that like i mean the the libertarian
like aspect of this is obviously very strong but
what's also neat is like you you meet and
interact with so many like so many different
types of people that are coming to this space
and then all of a sudden there's this like
exchange of ideas where we can start to like talk
through this i mean i i would say i'm libertarian
too but then i'm also coming from the legal
side and the compliance side where yeah so i
you know but i can't ever you know my stance isn't
like [ __ ] the government get like it can't be
right because part of this is helping companies
interact with these agencies to figure out a good
compromise and so it's yeah there's a lot of
compromising that has happened needs to happen
will continue to happen and we'll just you
know keep keep having baby steps but um but
no i mean this the the activity we're seeing
with the bitcoin price the companies we're
seeing getting in and you know involved like
tesla things like it's yeah we're it's crazy
this is what i wanted to ask you i'm just been
sidetracked on some things but i wanted to ask
you actually about that because microstrategy
put another 1.02 billion in today um these people
are mental and they're not mental they're
they're thought leaders and they're great
um but so they now own 95 so i think 95 of their
balance sheet is now bitcoin which is amazing but
we're hearing a lot about etfs we're hearing about
um what michael saylor has done to actually allow
other companies to invest through them um i
don't know the tech technical words for that
honestly i don't i understand what's happened
um but my question is essentially why can't
companies directly just buy bitcoin like tesla
did like square like microstrategy why is it so
difficult why did it why there's so many hurdles
i understand the price manipulation obviously
you don't want to move the market too much but
other than that from a regulatory standpoint
yeah it's a good question i mean honestly
i think part of what has made it made it
so companies haven't done it isn't as much the
regulatory hurdles but more like getting getting
the entire executive board or board of directors
on on on board with exposing their balance sheet
to this super volatile you know investment uh
in my mind like the the you know elon musk like
they are these like thought leaders and i think
that it'll it will pay off for them um and i i
but i but i think that that's part of it i mean
you know i keep kind of tying things back to
silvergate bank but like when silvergate when the
ceo alan lane went to like the board and said hey
you know i think this bitcoin thing is going
somewhere like i think we should you know create a
team of people that does business development and
legal and regulatory reviews blah blah blah like
you know i i can't like speak to the conversations
but my impression was that there was a little bit
of hesitation and it was sort of like this seems
like a gamble in a lot of ways like anything
involving cryptocurrency right now is still a
gamble and i don't mean like gambling i mean
it's a um there's a bit of like um trust
in in in it that that the future will
you know that it'll that it's here to stay and
that it'll be around for a long time and benefit
the people entering early um so i think that
that's part of it um and so wait just so i can
understand better than are you so going through
an etf or like going through what michael saylor
has essentially created is more protection for
the company and therefore everybody across the
board is more likely to get on board and be
more comfortable with this kind of investment
i'm not saying that as much and to be very candid
like i haven't worked with clients that are
looking to do what what these companies have done
so i don't feel like i can speak to it that much
in terms of like what what the process has been
for them but i i guess i'm saying more that like
the companies that we see who don't seem willing
yet to to make these big efforts um to get into
the crypto space i think part of the apprehension
is you know well we we even saw this week when
when bitcoin's price went down it hurt tesla's
stock right yeah 20 percent petersham i love
that yeah all of a sudden you're like tying
in i mean bitcoins obviously not a company but
you're tying in the reputational and success
of a certain uh project or you know currency
um yeah your balance sheet so that's that's more
what i'm saying and so but but i think that a
company that takes the time to to go through you
know have etfs and go through it that way like
yeah they've taken the time internally also to be
having these discussions yeah i think it goes back
to what you're saying about baby steps essentially
yeah yep yeah i mean yeah i mean i i definitely
maybe not right now with the the price doing what
it's i mean i don't really think the price drop
is that dramatic or that big thing still like
hovering around like what is it today what is
it let's see right now it's a 49 49 oh yeah 49 05
9. so i mean it's it's dropped quite quite a bit
but it's nothing i mean i remember when i was at
bitflyer it was bitcoin was hovering around 10k
and the day we launched it is what is the day
it went up to 20k as like brandon legal and
as in-house counsel and compliance i was freaking
out because i thought oh my god i mean day one
we have an influx of potential customers
because everyone's like excited about this
10 to 20k um you know but then then it was down
to 3k i mean it just so i don't think that the
price drop is that dramatic but i also think that
other companies like you know companies like apple
or amazon come to mind like some of these are also
forward-thinking companies and you know apple has
apple pay it seems like they are going to want to
to inch into this industry but they may be a lot
of companies may be sitting back and watching
what happens with tesla and just how it how it
works if they actually start uh accepting bitcoin
payments for tesla how the balance how it affects
their balance sheet and their stocks yeah so
people might just be like sitting back and watch
learning so speaking of like speaking of all this
crazy price movement then how's it been with like
friends and family is everybody just knocking on
your door like haley get us into bitcoin yeah are
they already in well so a lot i mean a lot of my
family and and friends i kind of like nudged in or
or sent a little bit of bitcoin to them for their
birthday or something so i'm trying to like i mean
i'm excited about the space and i uh like i i even
some usually when my kid when my friend's children
have birthdays i'll give them like twenty dollars
of bitcoin and like give the like i look too
like you're a present yeah i think so well it's
funny because i gave one of my friends like
three-year-old a little bit of bitcoin like i mean
i'm talking like ten twenty dollars of bitcoin
um but but then it then it like just shot up
and he was like i think it's worth like two
hundred dollars though you know and like it's so
so i you know and i just think it's neat to like
i always tell people about like coinbase urn or
these ways to like get involved or like lolly that
does the bitcoin um i don't know there's a lot of
ways to that i suggest people like get in without
feeling like they need to throw a bunch of money
into an exchange right away because that can be
kind of scary um but yeah i mean i it was a
funny story just came to mind my grandmother
passed away this week and um as i was sort of
like saying like talking to her what she was
unconscious you know like sort of in her final
days i was like grandma like bitcoin's at 57
000. and my mom goes hayley don't don't tell her
that member she wanted you to buy her some bitcoin
and it was just like it was just a sweet moment
you know like yeah because she my grandma was
always really excited about the space and actually
like i helped her give a presentation at her old
folks home about bitcoin and stuff so yeah it
was really she was really interested in it but um
anyways yeah i think uh yeah but i've but i've
had people like old friends and like people from
my past texting me oh i wish i had bought like
you told me to or i did thank you so much or oh
my god what a crazy month for bitcoin you know
so there's definitely a lot of like excitement
and um my the number of people impersonating
me on twitter has gone up so that's always
that's always a sign that the industry's doing
well but it's like it's never ending and really
annoying so but yeah i mean i think people
are getting more and more excited about it
and i think the tesla news hit hard because people
think of elon musk as as a visionary i mean he's
like building rockets to go into space he his card
designs are amazing i mean he's a little i tweeted
a while back like he's kind of like the perfect
person to be part of the crypto space because
he's a little crazy well unpredictable he's he
challenges the status quo like those are all
things that i think of bitcoin and itself and like
a lot of the people in the industry they're just
a little yeah they're challenging the status quo
and that's i think that's important yeah i think
we were all really surprised that it took him
that long but i heard maybe it was on clubhouse i
didn't i spent too much time there these days but
i heard somebody say that elon musk was playing
poker with bitcoin back back back way back when
yes like i'm talking years ago but i don't know
how if it's just a rumor or what but there's gonna
be like bitcoin poker day like we have bitcoin
pizza day if people if anyone can find out how
much he he lost that day that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah i'll be pretty insane well it was
kind of funny how he like was i mean he he
he promotes dogecoin you know but like i'm
like well add that's your balance sheet then
see that see i wasn't gonna go into this but
like that's an issue like that's that's an
issue because you and i and the majority of people
watching know that that's a joke but i'm not being
funny i had so many people intelligent smart
people approached me and asked me if doge is
a better investment than bitcoin because also
they feel like their priced out of the market
with bitcoin they've the ship has sailed um so i
had a friend who's like leia jojo's really cheap
elon musk is promoting it it's already up shall
i buy it now and i'm like girl calm yeah no yeah
well and what is i mean what is scary and
we like interesting about is i forgot so
i think it was like a year or two ago i started
opening accounts at every exchange just because
i kind of wanted to see all the uis you know like
see whatever yeah like what gemini looks like what
robin hood looks like what coinbase looks like
um and so as a result like i would just like
buy you know like 99 of my portfolio is bitcoin
but yeah with that one percent i was buying like
you know ten dollars of this ten dollars that i
totally forgot i bought fifty dollars of dogecoin
on robin hood like i don't know two
or three years ago and when i left
and i was just i was just going through like
the different accounts kind of looking at the
at the random coins i had bought you know
i bought that and a few others anyways but
when i looked at it it was like at an all-time
high and i and i cashed it out for like 22 2200
for so 50 to 200 and i was just like this is so
crazy that like i mean because it is a joke and
everyone kind of knows it's a joke but like if it
rallies like that and people are making money like
is it a joke like i don't i mean it's just really
weird but i'm sure people are losing money too
um i just got like lucky with the time like i
had totally forgotten about it but elon musk
was like tweeting about it and i was logged in
and i was like does that say doge and then i
saw the increase and i was like this is just like
i'm a secret genius yeah yes yes that must be it
yeah i mean it is concerning because i like people
wish that they put their life savings into bitcoin
so people are almost gonna do the same thing
with doge especially on clubhouse it's really
interesting because there's a lot of new people
see the thing with twitter is like is this echo
chamber of people already in a space yeah we don't
really have that kind of ability necessarily to
branch outside of the spaces i think it's a really
tight echo chamber but on clubhouse for some
reason um there's all these new people that can
and yeah it's really interesting and then they ask
us about doge and we were just like whoa like no
you know um not we're going on like tangent after
tangent but like i know it's okay i got an invite
you know so i'm technically on clubhouse but i've
never actually been i don't it's like is it that
like is it face to face talking or is it like
no uh do you know what i will i will get it
up on my phone um give me a sec let's see so
yeah like it's important it's just it's just
voice so it's just audio so let me just jump
into a room and everything it just looks like that
basically okay and and anyone can talk at any time
no so here you have the um speakers the
people with the blue are the mods they're
moderators i'm not blue sorry green can
you see they've got green sets yeah okay
and then it's actually really hilarious this
this thing so you scroll down and you have um
these are the special people so these people
so these people are followed by the um by the
speakers and then you have the people who are in
the dungeon down here who are totally irrelevant
and these are the so-called peasants who aren't
followed by anyone and nobody cares i'm joking
system on there i had no idea that's so funny
yeah there's a hierarchy it's really really funny
i um uh stephen and preston who are the other
two law partners i work a lot with at anderson
kill like they're both on it and i think speaking
and i jokingly told stephen yesterday like what
what are you all doing on there like do i need
to get on there like yeah you should i promise
you you should it's just like another thing to
check and do though you know it's like i know
and i've been to i've been like yeah well okay
i will no i'm with you i'm with you i'm with you
it's annoying having to manage all these different
whether it's managed work manage different social
media apps because now work is social media
um yeah so i mean definitely i think um
i even have clients that i talk to on like
telegram signal and so instead of like work
emails i'm getting like work messages all the
time from outside clients not just like inside
slack so yeah it's just crazy yeah it's mad um
i i don't think i do email anymore to be honest
it's all just it's all just telegram but anyway
we've been going for over an hour so it's been
such a cool chat haley thank you so much um it's
been really good yeah it's just been great i had
so many questions i wanted to ask you i'm always
kind of really interested in how what we're doing
will play out in in the wider world um and you
know regulation matters in that instance so
where can people find you show yourself oh okay
well yeah so my my handle is haley london btc
i think i think it's showing under my face right
now um but yeah i mainly i mainly am on on twitter
um i i don't i try not to do too many other
things but i guess i'll be on clubhouse now too
so so definitely follow and i'd love to come
back on your show like later this year or
next year when that when we're when we have
some updates on some of these topics like the
um ripple xrp litigation and and how the biden
administration has impacted us so so yeah i really
appreciate you reaching out and having me on your
show it was fun yeah it's been so amazing so haley
thank you so much again and guys thank you so
much for watching thanks for your comments i've
been reading them all and they're all really great
so i will see you all next week on thursday bye
bye